i've got to get to this kyle rittenhouse
story because it's kind of taken over
the internet and the public discourse
about about these riots in wisconsin
right now
so kyle rittenhouse 17 year old
kid you know teenager has been arrested
by police for first-degree murder
he he turned himself into the police
yesterday why we actually played a
little bit of this clip just sort of
offhand yesterday
kyle rittenhouse was walking around
during these riots
and he had an ar-15 and a group of
these rioters came up and started really
attacking him
and he defended himself take a listen
you see one guy kick him in the head
so then rittenhouse takes out his gun
and starts shooting people
and then the mobsters who are trying to
attack him
go away that's the purpose of a firearm
that is the purpose of self-defense we
have firearms a right to firearms in
this country
because of self-defense
so he shot at least two blm rioters
one of those writers by the way you're
probably not going to see this on the
mainstream media one of those rioters
attacking him
had a gun and is a convicted felon
so this is you forget about mostly
otherwise unarmed
this is as clear an example as possible
that this kid used his gun right by the
way the kid's a good shot
so the kid was he didn't he wasn't
shooting 10
000 bullets all over the place he wasn't
he was very precise and he
was able to get his attackers away from
him so the basic take on this i think is
self-defense it's very clearly
self-defense here
but it's not quite as simple as all that
there's apparently he may have shot his
gun
earlier and then people are reacting to
that
so we don't we don't have a great video
from from that
we don't know exactly was that in
self-defense too this clearly was was
that was he just out looking to snipe
people
from this video that seems unlikely
because he's got such good
discipline with his gun however i think
the self-defense argument
is it's not quite as simple because this
guy walked into a provocative situation
with a gun
he came here to this riot with a gun now
he says he wanted to protect people
right but other people might say he was
looking for trouble if you you know
leave your guns at home son don't take
your guns to town boy don't take your
guns to town
very wise words but it's not quite as
simple as all that
that he was looking for trouble and he
should have left his gun at home and
stay home played video games
because no longer can we rely
in many places on the civil authority
the civil authority is telling the
police to stand down
they've lost control of multiple cities
in the country
anarchy is raging everywhere so if i'm
more than happy to let the cops take
care of things and i
don't have to pick up my gun but if the
cops can't take care of things
if the civil government is not going to
ensure law and order and protect
our lives and property then we have to
protect them ourselves
it's just how it works another another
good reason for the second amendment
so what's the answer here what's the
answer
seems to me it was a bad idea for this
kid to take the gun out
and go to this place it's ruined his
life right he's going to be charged with
murder he might well be convicted 17
17 years old as a political matter now
this is all anyone's going to talk about
they're not going to talk about
the actual marauding criminals who
started the whole thing and were burning
the city to the ground over nothing
over cops doing their job
when a violent criminal sexual assailant
domestic abuser was resisting arrest and
then reaching into
a car that had a weapon in it but
otherwise was mostly unarmed
it from a personal standpoint it was
stupid
from a political standpoint it was
stupid it may have been somewhat
courageous but the line between courage
and recklessness
is a little bit blurry sometimes one has
to have prudence
and i just i i hope we should defend
this kid for
from what the evidence that we have we
should defend him because it was clearly
self-defense in that video
but on the other side we should not
encourage people to be doing this sort
of thing
it's completely counterproductive it's
what the left wants it's what the left
is trying to provoke
they're trying to provoke any kind of
right-wing violence here
so that they can focus on that through
the election which is what all of this
is about this is
all about the election they're willing
to see people die
for the election they're willing to keep
the economy completely shut down
which will cause suicides and overdose
debts it already has
to win an election what will that
election what's what's the sacred right
of that election
what is the issue that the left holds
more sacred than anything you see this
in the court judicial confirmation
hearings
you see it in in all of the debates
the right to kill a baby in the womb
they're all connected there is an
integrity of thought we talked about
integrity of thought with sister burn
there is an integrity of thought here if
you're willing to let cities burn to the
ground if you're willing to steal
people's property whether
through violent thugs or or the
government coming to your door
if you're willing to allow people to die
break a few eggs to make an omelet if
you're willing to kill babies in the
womb
there is an integrity of thought that
presents a world view
that is that in a certain sense is
coherent it all fits together
but when you look at human nature when
you look at who we are what we're here
for how we got here
it's completely incoherent those are the
choices
not every election not every political
situation
presents choices on life and death as
clear as that i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you